With all my favorite colors, yes, man, I've got all my favorite colors in lots. My sisters and my brother, see him like no mother. Hi, I'm here with Dr. Stephen Vasquez, the inventor of emotional transformation therapy, which you can get to Taproot in lots of other places. And we're going to talk today about just kind of science and innovation and the way that he came up that and how it works and i'll be honest you know when i came um to et t it was because i had all these people that had called me that connected with the stuff that i put out through the blog and podcast and i'm always looking for new models that are kind of the next thing and i was very
带着我所有最喜欢的颜色，是的，伙计，我有很多我最喜欢的颜色。我的姐妹和兄弟，看他就像没有母亲一样。嗨，我和情感转化疗法（ETT）的发明者斯蒂芬·瓦斯奎兹（Stephen Vasquez）博士在一起，你可以在Taproot和其他许多地方找到这种疗法。今天我们要谈谈科学、创新以及他是如何想出这个方法及其运作原理的。老实说，当我接触到ETT时，是因为有很多人打电话给我，他们与我在博客和播客上发布的内容产生了共鸣，我一直在寻找那种属于“下一个大事件”的新模型，我当时非常
credulous but they sounded very smart and i flew to texas and dr vascus was talking about you know paid all this money and dr vascus was talking about how color and light can heal trauma and have these effects and i was just like this is nonsense you know i i don't i don't think this will work and I volunteered, and I could not talk myself out of it. No, the effects of it are immediate. And there's kind of a, you know, with things like the spectral chart, there's a real immediate way that it's demonstrated. So I think having read a lot more of your work now and looked at your thought process,
容易轻信，但他们听起来非常聪明。我飞到了德克萨斯州，瓦斯奎兹博士谈到了——你知道，我付了那么多钱——瓦斯奎兹博士谈到了颜色和光线如何治愈创伤并产生这些效果，我当时就觉得这简直是胡说八道，你知道，我我不认为这会起作用。但我还是自愿尝试了，而且我无法说服自己放弃。不，它的效果是立竿见影的。而且，你知道，像光谱图这样的东西，有一种非常直接的演示方式。所以我认为，现在读了你更多的作品并研究了你的思维过程后，
the thing that is interesting to me about you that I think good science does is that you have big outside-the-box ideas, you know, that are new and different. But at the same time, you have a credulousness to say, okay, you know, I thought this was perfectly good guess, but that was bullshit. It didn't work and have enough skepticism to make sure that your big ideas are still like objectivity is replied to them, that they're reproducible. And I think that's really interesting. So a lot of your work came from reading other people's research and then noticing these brain pathways. And I was wondering if you could tell us about some of those devices because you built a couple of you talk about in the book.
关于你，我认为好的科学所具备的一点很有趣，那就是你有宏大的、跳出思维定势的想法，你知道，这些想法是新颖且与众不同的。但与此同时，你又有足够的轻信去说，好吧，你知道，我以为这是一个很好的猜测，但那是胡扯。它没起作用，并且你有足够的怀疑精神来确保你的宏大想法仍然符合客观性，它们是可重复的。我觉得这真的很有趣。所以你的很多工作来自于阅读他人的研究，然后注意到这些大脑通路。我想知道你是否能告诉我们其中一些设备，因为你在书中谈到了你制造的几个设备。
And some of them like shining light through skin, you discovered it was kind of a dead end. Like, it wasn't really the way to go. Right. But you did end up with three or four, you know, kind of really interesting devices and techniques I'd like to talk about. Yes. Originally, I was exposed to visual stimulation through syntonics optometry. It's a renegade group of optometrists that use colored light to correct vision problems. And I noticed that when people were using that, that emotional changes would take place.
其中一些，比如透过皮肤照射光线，你发现这是一种死胡同。就像，那并不是真正可行的方法。没错。但你最终确实得到了三四个，你知道，相当有趣的设备和技术，我想谈谈。是的。最初，我通过综合视光学（Syntonics optometry）接触到了视觉刺激。这是一群非主流的验光师，他们使用彩色光来矫正视力问题。我注意到当人们使用这种方法时，会发生情绪上的变化。
And I got intrigued with how the color affected emotional states more so than correcting the vision. And these were optometrists that didn't really do interpersonal work. They just had you look at light silently, 20 minutes per session. And, of course, as a therapist, I know that the bond between therapists and clients is a critical factor. And so I wanted to add that into the process. And I literally experimented people. I invited them to go through a counseling process while they looked at certain colors.
我对颜色如何影响情绪状态产生了兴趣，这比矫正视力更让我着迷。这些验光师并不真正从事人际工作。他们只是让你静静地看着光，每节课20分钟。当然，作为一名治疗师，我知道治疗师和客户之间的纽带是一个关键因素。所以我想要把这一点加入到过程中。我真的拿人做实验。我邀请他们在看着特定颜色的同时进行咨询过程。
And I didn't know for sure what would happen. And then I would have cases where dramatic changes would take place right away. In other cases where nothing happened. Well, it took me a while to figure out which thing could make it happen that well. One of the first ones was the woman and it had arthritic hands that were gnarled and she could she's been in pain for 15 years and
我并不确定会发生什么。然后我遇到了一些案例，戏剧性的变化立刻发生了。而在另一些案例中，什么也没发生。好吧，我花了一段时间才弄清楚是什么能让它发生得那么好。其中第一个案例是一位患有关节炎、手指扭曲的女性，她已经痛苦了15年，
nothing i tried looking at different colors nothing mattered until i got to orange and then all the pain went away i mean that and quickly so i'm thinking whoa there's a connection here i want to understand that so it took me a couple of years to actually get clear on which colors did what and under what circumstances but i was there are there is technology out there for all kinds of things with light stimulation, but they don't include the interpersonal part. In therapy, we know the research says no matter what the mental health approach is, the single factor that shows up to be the most significant is the bond between the therapist and
我尝试了观察不同的颜色，什么都没用，直到我换到橙色，然后所有的疼痛都消失了。我的意思是，而且很快。所以我心想，哇，这里面有联系。我想了解这一点。所以，我花了几年的时间才真正弄清楚哪些颜色在什么情况下起作用。但是，市面上确实有各种各样的光刺激技术，但它们不包含人际交往的部分。在治疗中，我们知道研究表明，无论心理健康方法是什么，最显著的单一因素是治疗师与
the client. So I needed to include that in the process, which is very different than just looking at a color. You just look at a color, it may or may not be helpful. But if the person is in a state of mind that that color responds to, big changes can happen pretty quickly. It's just a little history. So it was experimental for me. I had a strong sense it would work because I would get these dramatic changes here and there.
客户之间的纽带。所以我需要把它包含在过程中，这与仅仅看一种颜色是非常不同的。你只是看一种颜色，它可能有帮助，也可能没有。但如果这个人处于那种颜色所对应的心理状态，巨大的变化可以很快发生。这只是一点历史。所以对我来说，这是一种实验。我有强烈的预感它会起作用，因为我在这里和那里都看到了这些戏剧性的变化。
And I just had to figure out how to do that more accurately. And it's evolved over 25 years. And I've gone through, I think, maybe seven different. light devices in those 25 years, each one of them being more technologically advanced than the previous ones. And so that's a little bit about how that got started. Do you have a specific question? There's more I can say about this. Well, there's a couple devices that go along with ETT.
我只是必须弄清楚如何更准确地做到这一点。它在25年里不断演变。我想我在这25年里经历了大约七种不同的光设备，每一种都比前一种在技术上更先进。所以这就是它如何开始的一点背景。你有什么具体的问题吗？关于这一点我还有更多可以说的。好吧，有几个设备与ETT配套。
You know, there's a spectral resonance chart, which is just a chart with extremely expensive and accurate representations of the color spectrum. And then there's the light device, which, well, I'll save that for the end. There's the goggles which allow, you know, light in at a different angle against the pupil. And then there's the wands, which are an eye movement therapy that is, you know, similar to EMDR, brain spotting, but uses color. And then there's the light device, which kind of does all of the things, because you can add in a flicker rate, you can add in a color hue, you can add, so it mixes sort of all of them together. Yeah. Let me share you, share with you how that evolved. I actually started with the light device. It's a primitive light device had 11 colors. That was it. Now we have over 16 million, but that's how it started. And then I noticed that some people got overstimulated with the light device. It was too much for them. So I needed something else. And I had a personal experience where I was teaching in Germany. And I had one day off. And I was took on to train to go visit this famous castle there in Germany, you know Hswanstein. On the train, on the way over there, there were about five stops. And I was, at the time, I was pretty upset about a relationship I was in. And in Germany, each train station, the walls were painted a different color. One train station would be blue. The next one would be yellow. Third one would be orange. And as I came to look through my window at each train station, I worked on this issue that was disturbing me, and it worked.
你知道，有一个光谱共振图，它只是一张带有极其昂贵且精确的光谱表示的图表。然后是光设备，嗯，我会把它留到最后再说。有护目镜，你知道，可以让光线以不同的角度射入瞳孔。然后是魔杖，这是一种眼动疗法，你知道，类似于EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）、脑点疗法（Brainspotting），但使用了颜色。然后是光设备，它基本上完成了所有这些功能，因为你可以加入闪烁频率，可以加入色调，可以加入，所以它把所有这些都混合在一起了。是的。让我和你分享一下它是如何演变的。我实际上是从光设备开始的。那是一个原始的光设备，有11种颜色。就是这样。现在我们有超过1600万种，但这就是它的开始。然后我注意到有些人对光设备过度刺激。这对他们来说太多了。所以我需要别的东西。我有一个个人的经历，当时我在德国教书。我有一天休息。我乘火车去参观德国那座著名的城堡，你知道新天鹅堡。在去那里的火车上，大约有五个站。当时，我对我所处的一段关系感到非常沮丧。在德国，每个火车站的墙壁都漆成不同的颜色。一个火车站是蓝色的。下一个是黄色的。第三个是橙色的。当我透过窗户看着每个火车站时，我处理了困扰我的这个问题，它起作用了。
By the time I arrived to the destination, I was exhilarated because I had released all that distress. And so I saw that looking at a colored wall could do that much. And then I came across that particular chart that we use that was produced in France. And I began to work with that chart because I needed something that was not as stimulating as light into the eye. for people that got overstimulated rather easy. And so that's where I went to next. That's how the chart developed through my own personal experience with that
当我到达目的地时，我感到非常振奋，因为我已经释放了所有的痛苦。所以我看到看着一堵彩色的墙就能做到那么多。然后我偶然发现了我们在使用的那张在法国制作的特定图表。我开始使用那张图表，因为我需要一些不像射入眼睛的光线那样刺激的东西，给那些容易过度刺激的人使用。所以这就是我接下来去的地方。这就是图表通过我自己的个人经验发展起来的过程，
and discovering this chart that was produced in France. Since then, we've had trouble. The company, we bought 1,000 of those charts. We bought them out. The company is no longer in action, and we've been struggling to find a way to replicate it because the chart was pretty unique. The colors are extremely bright.
并发现了这张在法国制作的图表。从那以后，我们遇到了麻烦。那家公司，我们买了1000张那种图表。我们把它们买断了。那家公司已经不再运营了，我们一直在努力寻找复制它的方法，因为那张图表非常独特。颜色极其明亮。
as bright as you can get as clear as you can get but there's only seven colors and anyway so that's how that came about and then experimenting with it with different people uh i i noticed certain things and one of the big discoveries was sometimes the color would just distort completely they couldn't even see the color or else the whole chart turned gray or something like that would happen and i finally figured out that that had that was a visual distortion that indicated dissociated dissociation. If you can't see the color in front of you, but basically, you're not here psychologically. And so this is one of the most incredible tools for identifying dissociation. Most of the clients I get who have seen other therapists have been dissociative,
尽可能明亮，尽可能清晰，但只有七种颜色。总之，这就是它的由来。然后通过与不同的人进行实验，我注意到了一些事情。其中一个重大发现是，有时颜色会完全扭曲，他们甚至看不到颜色，或者整张图表变成了灰色，或者类似的事情会发生。我最终弄清楚了，那是一种视觉扭曲，表明了离解（解离）。如果你看不到面前的颜色，基本上，你在心理上并不在这里。所以这是识别离解最不可思议的工具之一。我接待的大多数看过其他治疗师的客户都有离解症状，
but the other therapists didn't know it. They couldn't recognize it. Yeah, it's hard to catch dissociation. It's hard. It's about that one. This comes up in seconds. And it's clear. So once we know, know that, then there's ways to treat that. Anyway, so the chart was powerful for a number of things. It could access information that was not conscious to the person, and it could show up dissociation. So it was a different way to work than light stimulation.
但其他治疗师不知道。他们无法识别它。是的，捕捉离解很难。很难。就是关于那一点。这在几秒钟内就会出现。而且很清楚。所以一旦我们知道了这一点，就有办法治疗它。总之，这张图表在很多方面都很强大。它可以获取人意识不到的信息，并且可以显示出离解。所以这是一种与光刺激不同的工作方式。
And so what happened next was the goggles. A Harvard psychiatrist named Schiffer developed what he called lateralized glasses. And he would just block off where you would see light coming in the left side of the eyes and then light coming in the right side. And they were a neuroscientist. He was a psychiatrist. And they understood that because they thought, oh, the right side of the brain,
接下来发生的是护目镜。一位名叫希弗（Schiffer）的哈佛精神科医生开发了他所谓的侧向眼镜。他只是阻挡了你从眼睛左侧看到的光线，然后是右侧。他们是神经科学家。他是一位精神科医生。他们理解这一点，因为他们认为，哦，大脑右侧，
the left brain hemisphere, the right brain hemisphere, and they were making a therapeutic difference. He wrote a book called Of Two Minds. And so I was crazy enough to think, well, I wonder if the light came in at 12 o'clock, o'clock if that would be it came in six o'clock and if it came in all the and I noticed that each one of them brought forth a different response and we even had a person that went to his office to tell them about it but they wouldn't accept it because they couldn't understand it any other way than right left brain hemisphere and so what
左脑半球，右脑半球，他们正在产生治疗上的差异。他写了一本名为《双重思维》（Of Two Minds）的书。所以我疯狂到认为，嗯，我想知道如果光线在12点钟方向射入，如果它在6点钟方向射入，如果它在所有方向射入会怎样。我注意到它们每一个都带来了不同的反应。我们甚至有一个人去他的办公室告诉他们这件事，但他们不接受，因为他们无法用除了左右脑半球之外的任何方式来理解它。所以我们
we discovered was a whole way to identify internal parts internal psychological parts and physiological parts by peripheral eye stimulation. So I got somebody to make these goggles for me, which only allow light to come in specific angles. And this was particularly good for people who got overstimulated because you're just barely letting in a little bit of light, particularly valuable with people with migraine headaches, particularly they had a sensitivity to light.
发现了一种通过周边视觉刺激来识别内部部分、内部心理部分和生理部分的完整方法。所以我找人帮我制作了这些护目镜，它们只允许光线以特定的角度射入。这对于那些容易过度刺激的人特别有效，因为你只是勉强让一点点光线进入，对于患有偏头痛的人特别有价值，特别是他们对光线敏感。
And so it was a breakthrough in that way, and we kept discovering more and more peripheral. angles that did more and more and brought forth information that were completely not conscious to the client so that's how that came about and now we've got more sophisticated goggles that can do much more but it's all about the angles of light coming into the eyes and it's generally gentler that's why it's so good for people to get overstimulated so we had that procedure and then the the Wands, how that happened with eye movement, in 1990, I was going to a training that I was
所以这在那种方式上是一个突破，我们不断发现越来越多的周边角度，它们做了更多的事情，并带来了客户完全没有意识到的信息。所以这就是它的由来。现在我们有了更复杂的护目镜，可以做更多的事情，但这一切都与光线射入眼睛的角度有关，而且它通常更温和，这就是为什么它对容易过度刺激的人如此有效。所以我们有了那个程序，然后是魔杖，眼动是如何发生的。1990年，我要去参加一个培训，我
to kind of do on a form of energy work I do. And on the way, I was reading the very first article that Shapiro wrote about EMDR. It was published in 1989. I didn't quite know what it was. I was seeing you hold your hands and move your, the person's eyes follow it in a certain way and that's all i mean didn't even finish the article and i got there and during this training serendipitously a gentleman had a birth trauma that was evoked i mean this was in front of 30 people and i'd never done this before and he had a birth trauma evoked right in front of everybody and i started doing this eye movement process with my fingers holding him up and moving them side to side And I didn't know what I was doing.
要进行一种我做的能量工作。在路上，我正在读沙皮罗（Shapiro）写的关于EMDR的第一篇文章。它发表于1989年。我不太知道那是什么。我看到你握着你的手，移动你的，那个人的眼睛以某种方式跟随它，就是这样。我的意思是，甚至没读完那篇文章，我就到了那里。在这次培训中，巧合的是，一位先生被唤起了一个出生创伤。我的意思是，这是在30个人面前，我以前从未做过这个。他就在大家面前被唤起了出生创伤。我开始用我的手指做这个眼动过程，支撑着他，并左右移动它们。我不知道我在做什么。
Like I said, I read about two-thirds of the first article. That was it. And he calmed down. The trauma seemed to settle down completely. Well, I still didn't think that much of it. And then five years later, I was in San Francisco again. And this gentleman signed up for a session with me. And I didn't know why.
就像我说的，我读了第一篇文章的三分之二。就是这样。然后他平静下来了。创伤似乎完全平息了。好吧，我当时还是没怎么想这件事。五年后，我又在旧金山了。这位先生报名参加了我的一个疗程。我不知道为什么。
And he told me that he had osteoporosis so bad. He'd tried Chinese medicine. He'd tried everything. Nothing worked. And that session, it all stopped when I did that with him. And so what we pieced together over time is that when the mother's giving birth, her bones soften during the time of the birth, and when the baby's bones soften also during the birth experience, if you have a trauma during the birth experiences, it gets fixated.
他告诉我他的骨质疏松症非常严重。他尝试过中医。他尝试过一切。什么都没用。在那次疗程中，当我对他做那个动作时，一切都停止了。所以我们随着时间的推移拼凑出来的是，当母亲分娩时，她的骨骼在分娩期间会变软，当婴儿的骨骼在分娩体验中也会变软。如果你在分娩体验中有创伤，它就会被固定下来。
And then later in life, when he was like 40 years old, stressors in his life evoked that birth trauma. And we corrected it in one session. And so then I began, by 1995, I began to think, okay, maybe there's something to this EMDR. Okay, so I began to exploring eye movements. And there are now three other forms of eye movement. One of them is eye movement integration developed by a psychologist in Canada.
然后在以后的生活中，当他大约40岁时，他生活中的压力源唤起了那个出生创伤。我们在一个疗程中纠正了它。所以到了1995年，我开始想，好吧，也许这个EMDR有点名堂。好吧，所以我开始探索眼动。现在还有其他三种眼动形式。其中之一是加拿大一位心理学家开发的眼动整合（Eye Movement Integration）。
Then there's brain spotting. Then there's EMDR. But what happened to me is during the 1990s, I didn't even know they taught EMDR. I didn't know that much about it. So I began to explore what kind of eye movement affected people psychologically. And I developed a whole system. By the time I really knew about EMBR and went to an EMDR training, I had already to develop this method.
然后是脑点疗法。然后是EMDR。但发生在我身上的是，在20世纪90年代，我甚至不知道他们教授EMDR。我对此了解不多。所以我开始探索什么样的眼动在心理上影响人们。我开发了一整套系统。当我真正了解EMDR并去参加EMDR培训时，我已经开发出了这种方法。
And so I go through the EMDR training, and it didn't seem to be nearly as impactful. And so unfortunately, I just didn't get trained in it or anything until maybe 10 years after I discovered that first article. And so I had all that time to explore. And that's why I came up with the different method of eye movement that we call multidimensional eye movement, simply discovering it on my own,
所以我参加了EMDR培训，它似乎并没有那么大的影响力。所以不幸的是，我直到发现那第一篇文章大约10年后才接受培训。所以我有了所有的时间去探索。这就是为什么我想出了我们称之为多维眼动（Multidimensional Eye Movement）的不同眼动方法，仅仅是通过我自己发现的，
watching people's eyes during emotional process, And so I found a very efficient way to use eye movements. It's, I mean, it changes people severe trauma in five to ten minutes. And one session I did that I just spoke about in our annual conferences, a woman had colorectal cancer. Okay, she had had it for some time. I was working with her. And she, as I did this eye movement process, she said she felt it.
在情绪过程中观察人们的眼睛。所以我找到了一种非常有效的使用眼动的方法。我的意思是，它在五到十分钟内改变了人们严重的创伤。我在我们的年度会议上谈到的一个我做过的疗程，一位女性患有结直肠癌。好吧，她已经患病一段时间了。我正在和她一起工作。当我做这个眼动过程时，她说她感觉它
go away and fortunately she had an appointment with a colorectal doctor and oncologist the next day and he said that if he didn't know her history he saw no sign that she even had colorectal cancer at all and so we eliminated that in that session with the eye movement so it's i mainly use it for we talk about PTSD but this is particularly good for acute trauma things that people are they're clearly emotional that's unresolved it's not like it's buried or something it's particularly good for acute trauma it's particularly good for visually initiated trauma something that they've seen that was scary or frightening and they can't get out of their mind an example is one gentleman i used it with um he came home one day and looked out his window and he saw his
消失了。幸运的是，她第二天预约了结直肠医生和肿瘤科医生。他说，如果他不知道她的病史，他根本看不出她曾经患过结直肠癌。所以我们在那个疗程中通过眼动消除了它。所以我主要用它来——我们谈论PTSD，但这对于急性创伤特别有效，那些人们显然有情绪、未解决的事情。它不像它是被埋藏的或什么的，它对于急性创伤特别有效。它对于视觉引发的创伤特别有效，他们看到了一些可怕或令人恐惧的东西，他们无法从脑海中抹去。一个例子是，我用它治疗的一位先生，他有一天回家，看向窗外，看到他的
16-year-old son hanging dead from a tree. Well, he couldn't get that picture out of his mind, of course. And we did that in 10 minutes. It was completely neutralized. Yes, he had some grief to deal with after that, but the actual visual image that was fixated was gone. And so it's particularly good for fixated visual images that just can't get out of your mind. That's my experience, too, is that the flashback re-experiencing is best treated with the ones. Whereas I feel like the goggles, the light direction goggles, or peripheral light stimulation goggles, have a, like, it's chronic pain, a lot of, like, things that have a somatic cause, but the emotion about the somatic pain that is a real pain, you know, is what you're kind of treating,
16岁的儿子吊死在树上。好吧，他当然无法把那幅画面从脑海中抹去。我们在10分钟内就完成了。它被完全中和了。是的，在那之后他还有一些悲伤需要处理，但那个被固定的实际视觉图像消失了。所以它对于无法从脑海中抹去的固定视觉图像特别有效。这也是我的经验，闪回重现最好用魔杖治疗。而我觉得护目镜，光线方向护目镜，或周边光刺激护目镜，有一种，就像，它是慢性疼痛，很多，就像，有躯体原因的事情，但你正在治疗的是关于躯体疼痛的情绪，那是一种真实的疼痛，你知道，
whereas the board is excellent for assessment. I just want to say a couple of things for people that may be kind of credulous, you know, and wondering about this stuff, you know, a lot of times somatic medicine or EMDR or any of that, you know, the more cognitive and behavioral people are kind of skeptical. I mean, one of the things that brought me into ETT was that when you're assessing on the board, which was the first thing that was demonstrated at the training, I mean, you get an immediate reaction that you can't explain because you lose the ability to see the color if you're dissociative. So for me, it was yellow. Like when I was at the training, I volunteered to go up and I kind of like, you know, EMDR, I'd seen work as a provider on patients, some patients that had real strong
而图表非常适合评估。我只想对那些可能有点轻信，你知道，并且对这些东西感到好奇的人说几件事。你知道，很多时候躯体医学或EMDR或任何这些，你知道，更认知和行为的人有点怀疑。我的意思是，带我进入ETT的事情之一是，当你在图表上进行评估时，这是培训中演示的第一件事，我的意思是，你会得到一个你无法解释的即时反应，因为如果你有离解，你就会失去看到颜色的能力。所以对我来说，是黄色。就像我在培训时，我自愿上去，我有点像，你知道，EMDR，我作为提供者在病人身上看到过它的工作，一些有非常强烈的
visual reexperiencing. But I, it never did anything for me as a provider. I just, or as a patient. It never did anything for me. And I was just kind of expecting to pick up a couple tips from ETT, but I didn't expect it to be as dramatic as it was in the neurology that you kind of discovered to be so profound. And so I went up and you did the screener on the board and based on what I was talking about said, you know, you need to look here. And it was like by yellow, yellow immediately turned black for me. Like I could not see it at all. And if I looked to yellow long enough, the entire board would turn black. And I mean, I even in the training, I touched it and you were like, no, no, don't touch the board. You know, they're $500.
视觉重现的病人。但我，它作为提供者对我从来没有任何作用。我只是，或者作为病人。它对我从来没有任何作用。我只是期待从ETT学到几个技巧，但我没想到它会像它在神经学上那样戏剧性，你发现它如此深刻。所以我上去了，你在图表上做了筛查，根据我谈论的内容说，你知道，你需要看这里。就像在黄色时，黄色对我来说立刻变成了黑色。就像我根本看不到它。如果我盯着黄色看足够久，整张图表就会变成黑色。我的意思是，我甚至在培训中碰了它，你说，不，不，不要碰图表。你知道，它们值500
dollars, please don't do that. Because I was like, you know, this is just printing on paper. I thought it was a screen or a trick. Like I couldn't explain why this was happening. And, you know, having done more processing myself and, like, gone through those things, I know what was at the root of a lot of, you know, feeling trapped and controlled and manipulated and boxed in that was making me dissociate around yellow, but that had gone on my whole life, you know, and when I was able to get the treatment with ETT and do some
美元，请不要那样做。因为我当时想，你知道，这只是纸上的印刷品。我以为它是一个屏幕或一个把戏。就像我无法解释为什么会发生这种情况。而且，你知道，我自己做了更多的处理，并且，就像，经历了那些事情，我知道很多，你知道，感到被困、被控制、被操纵和被束缚的根源，这让我围绕黄色产生离解，但这在我的一生中一直存在，你知道，当我能够得到ETT的治疗并做一些
of the, but so when you're assessing this, I mean, there's a, there's a fast reaction. that if you're a credulous person that thinks that what we're talking about is BS, I would just sit down with somebody and see something that you can't explain. You know, similar to me with the goggles. I had an ear infection when I was at the training and like my eardrum had ruptured. Like there was like, I was like wiping up blood that morning. And MJ, one of the trainers was like, well, this will be great because Joel had this ear thing. And I'm like, you know, guys, I didn't mom issues my way into this.
的时候，但所以当你评估这个时，我的意思是，有一个快速的反应。如果你是一个轻信的人，认为我们在谈论的是胡说八道，我建议你和某人坐下来，看看一些你无法解释的东西。你知道，类似于我和护目镜的经历。我在培训时得了耳部感染，我的耳膜破裂了。就像有，我那天早上在擦血。MJ，其中一位培训师说，好吧，这太棒了，因为乔尔有这个耳朵问题。我说，你知道，伙计们，我不是靠妈妈的问题才进入这个的。
Like I was wiping up blood this morning. And, you know, when that light and the goggles was at a three o'clock position, my ear was a five-alarm fire. And when it was at the like nine o'clock position, I couldn't feel anything. And it took her alternating between those four or five times before it was just like, you know, I can't explain this.
就像我今天早上在擦血。而且，你知道，当那个光和护目镜在三点钟位置时，我的耳朵就像五级火警。而当它在九点钟位置时，我什么都感觉不到。她在那之间交替了四五次，直到它就像，你知道，我无法解释这一点。
I'm really sitting there, you know, not believing it, you know, we see as trauma therapists, a lot of people that are pretty sick. You know, a lot of researchers who are more credulous, act like, you know, we're looking for people who are suggestible or something.
我真的坐在那里，你知道，不相信它。你知道，我们作为创伤治疗师，看到很多病得很重的人。你知道，很多更轻信的研究人员，表现得好像，你知道，我们在寻找容易受暗示的人或什么的。
But, you know, a lot of my patients are MDs and CEOs, and they're people who don't think that this work. anyway but are going to humor me and then it's transformative for them so I think the being open but also being credulous is like a good formula for kind of science and scientific innovation in the soft sciences like psychology and your work is a profound example of that yeah you're right a lot of people you know
但是，你知道，我的很多病人是医学博士和首席执行官，他们是不认为这有效的人，但会迁就我，然后这对他们来说是变革性的。所以我认为保持开放但同时也保持轻信，是心理学等软科学中科学和科学创新的一个好公式，而你的工作就是一个深刻的例子。是的，你是对的，很多人，你知道
come in thinking skeptical but when they they can't see the color in front of and they know it was there before sometimes it it gets their attention for sure something's happening, they can't explain. So it's very powerful. And it's a very common thing that happens that it does distort. So it's not, I'm going to say in most cases you're going to see that happen with the spectral chart. But that's how these things have evolved and now have discovered many more ways, applications for this to work. We have a whole protocol specifically for ADHD that eliminates it in three weeks for addictions,
进来时持怀疑态度，但当他们看不到面前的颜色，而他们知道之前它是存在的，有时这肯定会引起他们的注意，有些事情正在发生，他们无法解释。所以它非常强大。而且这是一种非常普遍的情况，它确实会扭曲。所以我不会说，在大多数情况下，你会看到光谱图发生这种情况。但这就是这些东西如何演变的，现在已经发现了更多的方法，应用来使它工作。我们有一整套专门针对ADHD的方案，在三周内消除它，针对成瘾，
that eliminates it in a matter of weeks. And, of course, depression, anxiety, although there's just protocols, ways to apply these things to very specific things. I should say some more about the goggles. Of course, IFS is very popular as an internal parts model. Well, this takes it to a whole new level. For example, I had a woman in a workshop where, you know, she had asthma.
在几周内消除它。当然，还有抑郁、焦虑，尽管这只是方案，应用这些东西到非常具体的事情上的方法。我应该多说一点关于护目镜的事情。当然，IFS（内部家庭系统疗法）作为一种内部部分模型非常流行。好吧，这把它提升到了一个全新的水平。例如，我在一个研讨会上有一位女性，你知道，她有哮喘。
Well, we found a position where she didn't have asthma. You can have pain in one position that can be not. Tonitis a lot of the time. I've had people that weren't even trying to treat it, have tinnitus spike and resolve with the gauze. But, I mean, whole conditions aren't there. We find parts where they don't have that condition, medical condition.
好吧，我们找到了一个她没有哮喘的位置。你可以在一个位置有疼痛，而在另一个位置没有。耳鸣很多时候也是。我遇到过甚至没有试图治疗它的人，耳鸣加重并用护目镜解决了。但是，我的意思是，整个状况都不存在了。我们找到了他们没有那种状况、那种医疗状况的部分。
So it's pretty significant for the physical part, which goes much further than IFS would typically go. And it's quick. It's very quick when that takes. place is just abruptly not there anymore yeah sciatica pain as a physician that demonstrated in front of a class and she was she wanted to ride horses is what her hobby was but you can't do that if you have sciatica because and her pain was pretty significant had been there for a while we did this in 20 minutes in the
所以这对身体部分非常重要，这比IFS通常会走的要远得多。而且很快。当它起作用时非常快。它只是突然不再存在了。是的，坐骨神经痛，作为一名医生在班级面前演示，她想骑马，这是她的爱好，但如果你有坐骨神经痛就不能那样做，因为她的疼痛相当严重，已经持续了一段时间。我们在20分钟内完成了这个，在
class I've checked with her a year later it's still gone and she is riding horses at this point and so forth. But, I mean, she was a physician. She had other ways to treat the sciatica. It didn't take it very far, and this eliminated. So, and probably one of the most exciting ones is one day, I had a person to come in that had cancer, and he had forgot to take his oxycodone that day.
班级里。我一年后和她核实过，它仍然消失了，她现在正在骑马，等等。但是，我的意思是，她是一名医生。她有其他方法来治疗坐骨神经痛。它没有走得很远，而这个消除了它。所以，而且可能是最令人兴奋的案例之一是有一天，我有一个人进来，他患有癌症，他那天忘记吃羟考酮了。
So he came into the office in severe pain, and we eliminated it with the goggles in 10 minutes. And his quote, which I love, says, this is better than any oxy-cotton I've ever used. So, I mean, I can see a lot of medical applications as well as psychological for this. But to many people that can't handle certain kinds of medication. So this gives you another option. Well, I think a lot of dissociation around specific types of emotion where people are either
所以他带着剧痛走进办公室，我们在10分钟内用护目镜消除了它。他的话，我非常喜欢，说，这比我用过的任何羟考酮都好。所以，我的意思是，我可以看到很多医疗应用以及心理应用。但对许多无法处理某些药物的人来说。所以这给了你另一个选择。好吧，我认为围绕特定类型情绪的很多离解，人们要么
enmeshed with the emotion, I've got to feel it all the time or avoidant of it. No, I can't feel that again. If I feel that, it'll kill me. So they're doing these other things to try and feel in control or to kind of justify that impaired emotional response. I think that shows up as ADHD and gets given riddle in quite a bit, you know, because it'll check the same symptoms on the DSM and it will respond to the same medication. But, you know, not having to deal with Adderall is, is cheaper and, you know, less medically risky.
与情绪纠缠在一起，我必须一直感受到它，要么回避它。不，我不能再感受到那个了。如果我感受到那个，它会杀了我。所以他们正在做这些其他事情来试图感到控制，或者为了证明那种受损的情绪反应是合理的。我认为这表现为ADHD，并且经常被给予利他林，你知道，因为它会在DSM上检查相同的症状，并且它会对相同的药物做出反应。但是，你知道，不必处理阿得拉（Adderall）更便宜，而且，你知道，医疗风险更小。
You know, a lot of this stuff clears that up. I'd like to talk a little bit about the dysneurobiology of these things because there are like, you know, a lot of people are just like, yeah, I mean, color maybe suggests, you know, memories that we have in the midbrain or, like, like associations from childhood and you're kind of playing with those somehow, but that's all you're observing. But what ETT is doing is not really stimulating the part of the brain that remembers, you know, the guy that picked me up from school one time had a red sweater on.
你知道，很多这些东西清除了它。我想谈谈这些东西的神经生物学，因为有，你知道，很多人只是说，是的，我的意思是，颜色可能暗示，你知道，我们在中脑拥有的记忆，或者，就像，来自童年的联想，你以某种方式玩弄它们，但这只是你在观察的。但ETT正在做的并不是真正刺激大脑中记忆的部分，你知道，那个有一次从学校接我的人穿着一件红色的毛衣。
It really is a deeper kind of brainstem response. Like we, we think that the, again, and there's studies on this. Like we have some of them I've written about the psychology of color in our blog. Like there's fMRI and QEG studies that when people look at shades of really far red, it activates the same networks.
它确实是一种更深层的脑干反应。就像我们，我们认为，再次，并且有关于此的研究。就像我们有一些我已经在我们的博客中写过关于颜色心理学的文章。就像有fMRI和QEG研究表明，当人们看非常深红色的色调时，它会激活相同的网络。
in the brain around bodily dissociation, what you see in phantom limb syndrome, what you see in gender dysphoria, what you see during dissociation around sexual assault. And it is a pretty implicit response that is kind of hardwired into the brainstem, not learned. And, you know, we think like most people think, or I thought, you know,
在大脑中围绕身体离解，你在幻肢综合征中看到的，你在性别焦虑中看到的，你在围绕性侵犯的离解期间看到的。这是一种相当隐含的反应，它被硬连线到脑干中，而不是学到的。而且，你知道，我们认为像大多数人认为的那样，或者我曾经认为，你知道，
before I started digging into this stuff at ETT training, that your optic nerve just plugs into the occipital lobe where the image is resolved, like the blu-ray cable, you know, the HTML cable goes from the Blu-ray player to the TV. But that isn't really true. There's 90% of those inputs on that V1 pathway. They wrap around the brain stem and then they're past juoccipital.
在我开始深入研究ETT培训中的这些东西之前，你的视神经只是插入到图像被解析的枕叶中，就像蓝光电缆，你知道，HTML电缆从蓝光播放器连接到电视。但那并不是真的。V1通路上的那些输入有90%它们绕过脑干，然后它们经过枕叶。
So you feel what you see before you actually see it. And when certain conditions you're talking about, you know, when curiosity's peaked, when somebody is in a feeling of safety, you know, I would hypothesize maybe when there's more of like a theta state present in the brain. That's when this color stuff starts to work and have that effect. And, you know, there's debate in neurology about why it is. that the object nerve passes that signal through the brainstem and the brainstem processes it before it goes to occipital and we see it some people feel like it's helping us react to things quicker you know the body can just take action the emotional system can just take action you know some neurologists have said that it's an efficiency thing it's an energy saving thing where the signal's being cleaned up so the syphidal doesn't have to do as much work but those connections are there i mean this isn't kind of fringe stuff you know if you care to look at how the brain is wired like it's apparent that these things have an effect um can you say anything more about that or kind of the neurological basis of that you found as you started you found
所以你在真正看到它之前就感觉到了你所看到的。而在你谈论的某些条件下，你知道，当好奇心达到顶峰时，当某人处于安全感中时，你知道，我会假设也许当大脑中存在更多像θ波状态时。那就是这些颜色东西开始工作并产生那种效果的时候。而且，你知道，神经学界对于为什么会这样存在争论。视神经将那个信号通过脑干传递，而脑干在它到达枕叶之前处理它，我们看到了它。有些人觉得它在帮助我们更快地对事物做出反应，你知道，身体可以只是采取行动，情绪系统可以只是采取行动，你知道，一些神经学家说这是一种效率问题，这是一种节能问题，信号正在被清理，所以枕叶不需要做那么多工作，但那些连接在那里，我的意思是，这不是边缘的东西，你知道，如果你关心看看大脑是如何连接的，你知道，很明显这些东西有影响。嗯，你能多说一点关于那个，或者你开始发现的神经学基础吗？
because we figure out that this stuff works and then we have to figure out why it works a lot of the time right um there there are a lot of what called um involuntary i call involuntary movement disorders from ADHD you see people you know hyperactively moving to excoriation to uh to Tourette syndromes, ultimately to essential tremor and Parkinson's. There's a number of things that have involuntary movement. The part of the brain that we access through specific wavelengths of red is in the basal ganglia. I'm trying to remember the name of the part in there, but there's a specific part of the brain that's in charge of movement. And what they do with Parkinson's, for example, there's a surgery that's used where they actually implant an electrode in that particular part of the brain.
因为我们弄清楚了这些东西有效，然后我们必须弄清楚为什么它有效，很多时候，对吧。嗯，有很多所谓的，嗯，非自愿，我称之为非自愿运动障碍，从ADHD，你看到人们，你知道，多动地移动，到抓挠，到，呃，抽动秽语综合征，最终到特发性震颤和帕金森病。有很多事情有非自愿运动。我们通过特定波长的红色访问的大脑部分是在基底神经节中。我正在努力记住那里的部分名称，但大脑中有一个特定的部分负责运动。他们对帕金森病所做的是，例如，有一种手术被使用，他们实际上在大脑的那个特定部分植入了一个电极。
It's called a substantia nigra that's in charge of movement. And so they're using this by giving them surgery. They haven't figured out that you can get it through the eyes without a surgery. But you literally see people's involuntary movement stop. I have two cases of Restless Lig syndrome where we did spec brain scans before and after, and you could see that part of the brain is completely stopped. This thing, the whole syndrome stopped and didn't come back. We checked a year later, did another brain scan.
它被称为黑质（substantia nigra），负责运动。所以他们通过给他们做手术来使用这个。他们还没有弄清楚你可以在没有手术的情况下通过眼睛得到它。但你确实看到人们的非自愿运动停止了。我有两个不宁腿综合征的案例，我们在之前和之后做了SPECT脑部扫描，你可以看到大脑的那部分完全停止了。这个东西，整个综合征停止了，并且没有回来。我们一年后检查，做了另一次脑部扫描。
It was still normalized. So that's one, wavelengths of red over time, I figured out that that's what it's doing. It's affecting the part of the brain involved in movement, the substantia nigra which lies in the basal ganglia and then there's other things other discoveries that happen one of them is really common with trauma issues if a person is traumatized yes let's say they're raped you process the rape that's fine they're better mostly but the research says that for example women have been assaulted are four times more likely to be assaulted again. Now that's a peculiar phenomenon. Most therapists have seen this. You have people that
它仍然是正常化的。所以那是其中之一，随着时间的推移，红色的波长，我弄清楚了那就是它正在做的事情。它正在影响大脑中涉及运动的部分，黑质，它位于基底神经节中。然后还有其他事情，其他发生的发现。其中之一在创伤问题中非常普遍。如果一个人受到创伤，是的，假设他们被强奸了，你处理了强奸，那很好，他们大部分时间都好转了。但研究表明，例如，被侵犯的女性再次被侵犯的可能性高出四倍。现在这是一个奇特的现象。大多数治疗师都见过这个。你有人们，他们
they have things over and over. But what happens is once you've disrupted a part of the brain that's called the temporal parietal juncture, that part of the brain is in charge of identifying separating self from others. And if it's affected by trauma, it doesn't work that way anymore and you're more susceptible to being affected by external stimuli. And we found that a specific wavelength of red or orange, not red, not orange, affects that particular part of the brain. And we can build boundaries to where, let's say, if a person's rape, they go through the trauma, but to also correct that, that loss of perceived boundaries,
一次又一次地有这些事情。但发生的事情是，一旦你扰乱了大脑中被称为颞顶交界处（temporal parietal juncture）的部分，大脑的那部分负责识别分离自我与他人。如果它受到创伤的影响，它就不再那样工作了，你更容易受到外部刺激的影响。我们发现特定波长的红色或橙色，不是红色，不是橙色，会影响大脑的那个特定部分。我们可以建立边界，到哪里，假设，如果一个人被强奸，他们经历了创伤，但也纠正了那个，那种感知边界的丧失，
then that protects them from it happening again, which is to me, I think that's what's missing in a lot of therapy. Fine, you do the trauma and that's helpful, but their brain has changed forever because of that because it's affected that part of the brain that can't differentiate self from other, and therefore you're more susceptible to being impacted by things, external stimuli, even stimuli like light and sound,
那么这就保护了他们免受再次发生这种情况，这对我来说，我认为这就是很多治疗中缺失的东西。很好，你处理了创伤，那很有帮助，但他们的大脑因为那个而永远改变了，因为它影响了大脑中无法区分自我与他人的那部分，因此你更容易受到影响，受到外部刺激，甚至像光和声音这样的刺激，
as well as other people. And so those two, there's other wavelengths of light that affect specific parts of the brain. Those are two of them that I think are really significant that we discovered. Would you say that that's why Orange is so important for like Dissociative Identity Disorder and Dissociative Disorders that kind of, it seems like it's sort of egoic coherence. Right.
以及其他人。所以那两个，还有其他波长的光影响大脑的特定部分。那是我们发现的其中两个我认为非常重要的。你会说这就是为什么橙色对于像离解性身份识别障碍（DID）和离解性障碍如此重要的原因吗？那种，看起来它有点像自我连贯性。没错。
You know, Indigo is like relationship between parts of self, but communication between internal parts of self. But Orange is more like just a coherent center and a cohesive narrative of. Yes. of the self, I think. Well, almost everybody who's been traumatized, they're not just traumatized, but their identity has been impacted by it.
你知道，靛蓝色就像自我部分之间的关系，但内部自我部分之间的交流。但橙色更像是一个连贯的中心和一个连贯的叙事。是的。关于自我，我想。好吧，几乎每个受到创伤的人，他们不仅仅是受到创伤，而且他们的身份也受到了影响。
They see themselves as a broken person or somehow deficient because of the trauma. Now, the truth of the matter is they're the same, but they perceive themselves as less than once the trauma has affected them. And so it impacts self-perception. And Orange is a key element for that. for working with self-perception that literally changes it to where with ETT, an essential part of it
他们因为创伤而认为自己是一个破碎的人或在某些方面有缺陷。然而，事实是他们本质上没有变，但创伤发生后，他们觉得自己不如从前。这影响了自我认知。而橙色是改善自我认知的关键要素，在ETT中，它能从根本上改变这一点，这是其核心部分。
is you have to be in touch with the emotion that you want to change in order for the light to have that kind of an impact. So that's because emotions become more susceptible to change when you're experiencing them. Yeah, memory reconsolidation theory can kind of explain a lot of how the board is working because what I tell patients that have done brain spotting with me is
你需要与想要改变的情绪保持联结，光照才能产生那种影响。这是因为当你正在体验情绪时，它们更容易发生改变。是的，记忆重组理论可以在很大程度上解释这种机制。我告诉那些和我一起做脑点定位（Brainspotting）的患者，
you know brain spotting is going to suck you into that feeling like you're going to not be wanting to feel anything and I'm going to find this spot where I see a pupil dilation and you're not going to feel it for a minute and then you go into it and they're used to that happening where they almost kind of involuntarily or without participation get pulled into the emotion the board doesn't work like that I mean just looking at the color doesn't pull you into the response it takes you feeling the feeling to get that dissociation and so it's like like people are looking at the board and they're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, just talk about the issue.
脑点定位会把你吸入那种感觉中，让你不想感受任何东西，而我会找到那个我观察到瞳孔放大的点。你可能有一会儿感觉不到，然后你进入了那种状态。他们习惯了这种几乎是不由自主地、无需参与就被拉入情绪的过程。但色板（Board）的工作方式不同，仅仅看着颜色并不会把你拉入反应中，你需要去感受那种感觉才能产生解离。所以人们看着色板时会说，是的，是的，就谈论这个问题。
And they're like, yeah, yeah, my mom made me feel small. And then I, I see him kind of look because I know they saw something, but they still don't want to know that it worked. Like, all right, keep telling me, you know, she would always make me feel like I just didn't. And then they'll stop again and they'll look and I'm like, what are you seeing in green? What are you seeing?
他们会说，是的，我妈妈让我觉得自己很渺小。然后我看到他们眼神有些变化，因为我知道他们看到了什么，但他们仍然不想承认这起作用了。我说，好吧，继续告诉我，她总是让你觉得你不够好。然后他们又停下来，看着色板，我问，你在绿色中看到了什么？你看到了什么？
I think my eyes are just doing something weird. And it takes, you know, kind of six or seven times of them feeling that thing. And then seeing the distortion form, then we can kind of see how it works, that it is this form of immediate biofeedback. for the emotions that you cannot handle and that you may feel intellectually like you're able to feel trapped or controlled or manipulated, whatever emotion you're working with. And these are implicit emotional states in the brainstem, not thinking, abstracted emotion,
我想我的眼睛只是在做一些奇怪的动作。这需要他们感受那种东西六七次，然后看到扭曲形成，我们才能明白它是如何运作的。这是一种即时的生物反馈，针对那些你无法处理的情绪。你可能在理智上觉得被困住、被控制或被操纵，无论你正在处理什么情绪。这些是脑干中隐含的情绪状态，而不是思考或抽象的情绪，
but implicit early emotional states, you know, it takes them a minute to realize, like, my brainstem is out of the window of tolerance there. It can't feel this, even if I think I can feel it and I'm unaware of it, I can't feel this. And then the real work begins. And, you know, I get emails from people all over the country that, you know, say, like, I'm a crank because I do brain spotting, or I like some of the metaphors that Carl Jung drew or that I do, you know, ETT. And so, like, I shouldn't have a license because, you know, whatever. You know, they've just taken their first research 101 class. It's usually clinical psychology grad students that are real early on. But, like, you know, we both have seen patients that have done the more manualizable forms of therapy that randomized control. trials like that, you know, have a place and do provide some benefit like CBT and DBT and ACT and RABT for years. Some of these patients have been in that.
而是隐含的早期情绪状态。他们需要一点时间才能意识到，我的脑干已经超出了耐受窗口。即使我认为我能感觉到且并未察觉，但我实际上无法承受这种感觉。然后真正的治疗才开始。我收到全国各地人们的邮件，说因为我做脑点定位，或者我喜欢卡尔·荣格的一些隐喻，或者我做ETT，我就是一个疯子，我不应该拥有执照。他们通常只是刚上完第一门研究方法课的临床心理学研究生。但我们都见过那些做过更具手册化治疗的患者，比如随机对照试验支持的CBT、DBT、ACT和RABT，他们做了多年，但依然如此。
But the level of what this works on in the brain and how deep it goes, I mean, I think is a place that a lot of people just have a really hard time, even when they want to get better and they're trying to focus on these things in like a purely relational or cognitive therapy. And in ETT and brain spotting, I mean, suck you into a different part of the brain in a different way of being with an emotional experience that are under language, you know, that are under objective thought, that are more like an emotion as an energy that is just activating that now you can start
但这种方法在脑部起作用的层面以及深度，我认为是很多人即使想要好转，并且试图在纯粹的关系或认知治疗中专注于这些事情时，也感到非常困难的地方。在ETT和脑点定位中，它将你吸入大脑的不同部分，以一种不同的方式与情绪体验共处，这些体验处于语言之下，处于客观思维之下，更像是一种正在激活的能量，现在你可以开始
to have a relationship with. And I think that's why the parts-based languages like IFS and Lifespan and, you know, voice dialogue, why they kind of meld with this pretty well. And they naturally make those like a great extension of people that are already doing good work with parts-based and semantic therapy. Yeah, it's a repression, an avoidance defense, that over time becomes automatic and all these buried emotions pile up inside a person affect them, but the person themselves doesn't even know where they're coming from. So with ETT, almost every session, people have new awarenesses, the sources, the roots of their anxiety or their depression become clear. And without that, what happens is you're going to have to fix it over and over.
与之建立关系。我认为这就是为什么像IFS（内部家庭系统）、Lifespan和语音对话（Voice Dialogue）等基于部分的语言能与此很好地融合。它们自然地成为了那些已经在进行基于部分和躯体治疗的优秀工作者的绝佳延伸。是的，这是一种压抑和回避的防御机制，随着时间的推移变得自动化，所有这些被埋藏的情绪堆积在一个人内心，影响着他们，但当事人甚至不知道这些情绪从何而来。因此，通过ETT，几乎在每次疗程中，人们都会有新的觉察，焦虑或抑郁的根源变得清晰。如果没有这一点，你将不得不反复修复它。
But if you can get the... Or just white knuckle it through life because you know what you're supposed to do, but the emotion is still disregulating your behavior. You feel powerless and helpless. And when it's not conscious, you don't have much of a shot at fixing it by yourself. So this brings these things to conscious awareness, and then we resolve them. That's why the depth of it affects longevity when we make a change.
但如果你能……或者只是咬牙坚持生活，因为你知道你应该做什么，但情绪仍在干扰你的行为。你感到无力和无助。当它不是有意识的时候，你自己几乎没有机会修复它。所以这把这些东西带到了意识层面，然后我们解决它们。这就是为什么它的深度会影响我们做出改变后的持久性。
and it's just exciting as a therapist is exciting in fact one of my interns she said there's no way you can have burnout on this it's too exciting yeah yeah you see a person make a major turnaround I mean you're not going to get burned out they're going to get excited then her question was what do I do with my excitement after this and so we share it with each other and that's one way to deal deal with it um so did you have a another issue or question you want us to well i'd like to be respectful of your time um you know this is a pretty good overview i think for people that are wanting to find out more about et t or to get trained because i really do feel similar to brain spotting that this is just a pretty natural extension of any other effective type of therapy that it really i mean like a lot of times with me like i'll have talked to a patient for a long time and they're using the word angry but you know that isn't really the emotion i can't really figure it out maybe they're not able to put
作为一名治疗师，这令人兴奋。事实上，我的一位实习生说，做这个绝对不会感到职业倦怠，因为它太令人兴奋了。是的，当你看到一个人发生重大转变时，你不会感到倦怠，你会感到兴奋。她的问题是，在此之后我该如何处理我的兴奋感？所以我们互相分享，这是处理它的一种方式。那么，你还有其他问题或想讨论的话题吗？我想尊重你的时间。我认为对于那些想要了解更多关于ETT或想要接受培训的人来说，这是一个很好的概述。因为我确实觉得它和脑点定位一样，是任何其他有效治疗方法的自然延伸。很多时候，我和患者谈了很久，他们一直在用“愤怒”这个词，但你知道那并不是真正的情绪，我无法真正弄清楚，也许他们无法表达
exactly, you know, the conceptualization around the emotion, but we get on the board and immediately the color that goes black is what we're working with. And a lot of times it makes sense. I mean, it really helps them understand how they're really feeling what is really coming up and they kind of immediately are like, oh, okay, yeah, you know, I wouldn't allow it to feel angry. So I was calling this, you know, I was calling this like something else, but really that's what it is. I don't feel like I can have a voice. And, you know, a lot of that is just so interesting and so helpful for therapists that are curious and really want to always be prepared to handle the next thing that they don't know how to handle.
准确地说，关于这种情绪的概念化，但当我们使用色板时，颜色立即变黑，这就是我们正在处理的东西。很多时候这很有意义。它确实帮助他们理解他们真正的感受，以及真正浮现出来的是什么。他们会立即说，哦，好的，是的，我不允许自己感到愤怒。所以我把它称为其他东西，但实际上就是这样。我觉得我无法表达自己的声音。这对于那些好奇并希望随时准备好处理他们不知道如何处理的事情的治疗师来说，是非常有趣且有帮助的。
You know, there's a lot of tools here. Do you have anything to kind of cap us out that is helpful that you kind of would like to say to providers that may have questions or be interested about how to find out about ETT? Oh, sure. I mean, we have a website that has all the trainings coming up. We've got about 10 people that are trained to be facilitators for ETT. And I only do them here in Austin, Texas. where I am, and we have people around the country that train this,
这里有很多工具。你有什么总结性的建议，可以帮助那些可能有疑问或对了解ETT感兴趣的提供者吗？哦，当然。我们的网站上有所有即将进行的培训。我们大约有10个人被培训为ETT的引导师。我只在德克萨斯州奥斯汀这里进行培训，我们在全国各地都有人进行这种培训，
and even one of them in Europe, that will do trainings from there. So it's available on our website. Do you only need to give that address? I can put all that in the show notes. And so anybody can click the link. If they're on the YouTube or if they're on the podcast, you'll see that link to the ETT training beneath. So you can find out more about the model
甚至在欧洲也有一位，他们会从那里进行培训。所以这些信息在我们的网站上都有。你只需要提供那个地址吗？我可以把所有这些都放在节目说明里。这样任何人都可以点击链接。如果他们在YouTube或播客上，你会在下方看到ETT培训的链接。所以你可以了解更多关于该模型的信息，
and then also register for a training if you'd like. like to. Particularly brain spotting and EMDR providers. I mean, I think this kind of continues to enhance what you're doing and it would probably be a good extension of those. There's never been a study that actually compare them, but I get therapists all the time who have been doing EMDR particularly and then they no longer do that after we, they get EMDR. So that happens repeatedly. So that's their perspective on it but they haven't actually done an actual study on it but I'm open to that if and when that would ever take place so it's it's taught the seven courses let me explain the first course covers two two methods the multi-dimensional eye
然后如果你愿意的话，还可以注册参加培训。特别是脑点定位和EMDR的提供者。我认为这进一步增强了你正在做的事情，它可能是这些方法的良好延伸。虽然从未有过直接比较它们的研究，但我经常遇到那些一直在做EMDR的治疗师，在他们学习了ETT之后就不再做EMDR了。这种情况反复发生。这就是他们的观点，虽然还没有进行实际的研究，但如果未来有这样的机会，我是持开放态度的。它教授七门课程，让我解释一下，第一门课程涵盖两种方法：多维眼动
movement and the use of the spectral chart the second course involves the light device as well and gosh I'm always going to blank here in the second course, the light device and the goggles, okay? The third course has specific applications to the most common psychological challenges, depression, anxiety, trauma, OCD. So it covers a variety of things, but it's mostly trauma focused, and you become certified as a ETT complex trauma therapist after that. The fourth one focuses on somatic issues like physical pain, stress-related illness, sleep disorders, things of that nature on the fourth course. The fifth course is the spiritual and religious issues, and a lot of people have
和光谱图的使用。第二门课程也涉及光设备，天哪，我总是会在这里卡壳，第二门课程是光设备和护目镜，好吗？第三门课程针对最常见的心理挑战有具体的应用，如抑郁、焦虑、创伤、强迫症。所以它涵盖了各种各样的事情，但主要是以创伤为重点，之后你将获得ETT复杂创伤治疗师的认证。第四门课程侧重于躯体问题，如身体疼痛、压力相关疾病、睡眠障碍等。第五门课程是关于精神和宗教问题，很多人都有
those kinds of issues. The six courses on addictions. So number six is addiction. The seventh course is on couple therapy, how you apply this to couple therapy. So those are the seven basic courses we teach applications for ETT. So anyway, that's some information I think people need to have. I do, I start in January with level one and we go through the whole year all seven by the time we get to the finish. But there's other people in other parts of the country that are teaching it at different points.
这类问题。第六门课程是关于成瘾的。所以第六门是成瘾。第七门课程是关于夫妻治疗，如何将其应用于夫妻治疗。所以这就是我们教授ETT应用的七门基础课程。总之，我认为人们需要了解这些信息。我确实在1月开始第一级课程，我们全年进行，到结束时完成所有七门课程。但在全国其他地方也有其他人在不同时间教授它。
Well, thank you so much for your time. We'll link to all of that. And if you have any interest, please go to the website, find out some more about ETT. I do think it's a pretty natural extension of what a lot of good providers. are already doing and just gives you some more tools in your toolbox so thank you so much for talking with us and we look forward to talking with you again thank you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢你的时间。我们会链接到所有这些内容。如果你有任何兴趣，请访问网站，了解更多关于ETT的信息。我确实认为它是许多优秀的提供者已经在做的事情的自然延伸，只是为你提供了更多的工具。非常感谢你与我们交谈，我们期待再次与你交流。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。